تصميم الطالبات في ايران في ازدياد مئات
الضحايا ورد السلطات مؤامره من العدو
وليفربول يهزم مانشستر يونايتد 7-0 لكن
نسيت الفوز كله راح لرونالدو وفريق زامبي
يدخل الملعب من فوق السور خوفا من السحر
اهلا بكم
مازال الغموض بيحيط بمشاهد التسمم اللي
بترتكب بحق الطالبات الايرانيات في
المدارس من نوفمبر واللي زادت بشكل مهول
من ايام يعني في الاول كانوا كم حادثه
متفرقه والان عشرات المدارس ومئات
الاصابات اللي يصير تحديدا انه الطالبات
وهم ما داخل حرم الجامعه بيبداوا بشكل
جماعي بتظهر عليهم اعراض تسمم والكلام عن
انه التسمم بغاز في الجو مو معروفه طبيعته
بالضبط وبيتنقلوا طبعا للمستشفيات فورا
والاعداد جلسه يوم عن يوم بتزيد ايران
اليوم بتتكلم عن اكثر من 80 مدرسه و700
اصابه اليوم فقط
[موسيقى]
لليوم ما في اي اجابه واضحه من السلطات
الايرانيه عن المتورطين والمسؤولين وحقيقه
كما التصريحات اللي بنسمعه كثير ولكن
للامانه ما في اي احد قال مين هو المتورط
في هذه الحوادث اللي جالسه بتصير واحدث
التصريحات كانت للمرشد الاعلى ايه الله
خامنا ايه اللي طلع وقال انه هذه جريمه لا
تغتفر ويجب محاسبه المتورطين
العسكريه
انجي نويت
محكوم
بشانو اشد مجازات
الرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي ما اختلفت كثير عن
خامنئي فخامه
هذه القصه ومتورطه فيها ورئيسي قال انه
اللي جالس بيصير مؤامره من العدو وانها
حلقه اخرى من سلسله المؤامرات اللي يعني
بيحيكها الاعداء بهدف اثاره التوتر
والتهويل داخل المجتمع الايراني ونشر
الخوف بقلوب المواطنين وكمان كان طلع رئيس
السلطه القضائيه تعهد انه ما راح يتساهلوا
ابدا في معاقبه المتورطين وراح يعدموهم
ووصفهم بالفاسدين يعني مثل ما سمعتوا كل
تصريحات وعود بالمحاسبه ومؤامرات خارجيه
وداخليه ولكن للان ما في اي طرف خيط عن
الفاعل والجهه اللي بتسوي هذا الشيء لا
زالت مجهوله فالسلطه جلست توجه تهديدات
اعيدهم اصلا مو عارفين مين ولا قادرين حتى
يوجهوا اتهام لاحد الا لايادي خارجيه
ومجهوله وهذا الشيء خلى ذوي الطالبات
يطلعوا طبعا في احتجاجات ويتجمعوا امام
مبنى وزاره التربيه والتعليم علشان من
حقهم يعرفوا ايش اللي جالس بيصير ولكن
السلطات الايرانيه بدل ما تقول لهم المفيد
واللي ممكن يريحهم اعتقلت العشرات منهم
وهذه الاعتقالات ما اوقفت الناس بالعكس
زادت من الدعوات مو بس لاهالي الطالبات لا
للكل علشان ينزلوا ويحتجوا على السلطات
اللي كثير من الناس غير انه بتحملهم
مسؤوليه استمرار حوادث التسمم في كثير
منهم جالسين تهمه السلطات تحديدا انهم
وراء اللي جالس بيصير او الجماعات
المتشدده اللي تابعه لهم بالاساس
تنضم الينا السيلاوي الباحثه في الشان
الايراني من بروكسل اهلا فيك معنا منى
يعني صراحه اللي بيصير عجيب وغريب جدا هل
عندك اي تفسير او معلومات عن القصه هذه
تحياتي لك وللمشاهدين يعني صحيح انه
النظام يتضايق انه هو ضحيه وبالفعل هناك
ايادي خارجيه ومؤامره خلف هذه هي الاعمال
ولكن طبيعه النظام وتاريخنا مع هذا النظام
يدل انه هم خلف هذه القضيه وهذه الهجومات
واذا اذا كانوا بالفعل صادقين انهم يريدون
ان يعرفون من هو خلف هذا الاعمال لم
يكونوا
باعتقال الصحفي علي طبطباء يفور الذي هو
كتب عن قضيه التسمم في مدينه قوم نظام قم
باعتقاله يعني كيف يقولون نحن نريد
ان نفيقون باعتقاء باعتقال صحفيين
يحاولوا بهذا الامر
ايضا وعود باعتقال مثلا اشخاص المتورطين
في قضيه قتل
التي كانت حصلت في مدينه كرمان ومشهد اللي
كانوا يقتلون من نساء اللي كان يمارسن
الدعاره ايضا النظام وعد وقدم كثير من
الوعود ولكن في النهايه على الرقم اصدار
حكم الاعدام قاموا باخذ رضايه اهل الدم
ولم يقوموا باعدام هؤلاء الافراد يعني على
الرغم ان انا شخصيا ضد حكم الاذان ولكن
هناك ازدواجيه معايير في قضيه التعامل مع
هكذا قضايا في حال نرى
استمر هذه الحوادث من ثلاثه اشهر حتى الان
لم يقوم باعتقال اي شخص في حال المحتاجين
اللي قاموا بحرق يعني سله زباله قاموا
باعدامهم يعني ليس
قبل لكن هو النظام خلفه وهذا لانه نظام
يتغذى
على سيسبب له مشاكل بل لذلك يستمر مع
الازمات وهذه ازمه يعني مختلقه من قبل
النظام حتى يحاولون ان يسيطروا على شارع
الايراني بعدما عجزوا من خلال
القمه من خلال طريق امنيه ان يسيطر على
الشارع المحتج في ايران ولكن يعني يمكن
لها رد فعل عكسي او ادباك فايروس زي ما
بيقولوا لان الناس برضو جالسين بيقولوا ان
النظام الايراني هو اللي وراها وبرضه
نزلوا باحتجاجات جديده يعني يعني يبدو
الاسلوب فشل
الطريقه نجح مع النظام الايراني ولكن في
النهايه الحالات الاجتماعيه الشعوب صعب
بالنهايه التنبؤ بهم ممكن واحد يتنبا انه
نعم مع هذه
هجومات ممكن الناس يتخوف ان لا يرسل بناته
الى المدرسه ان يجلس
[موسيقى]
ويكونوا هم النار هذه الثوره فيريدون
يحذفون النساء من هذا الحراك طيب الى متى
النظام الايراني دائما كل ما حيصير عنده
شيء حيقول مؤامره خارجيه هذه مؤامره
خارجيه يعني بيدخلوا تحتها كثير ناس يعني
الصراحه
بالفعل كل كل الانظمه استبداديه هكذا
عندما يعجز ان يقوموا بما لازم يقوموه
يقولون اما انها مؤامره خارجيه او بسبب
دول الغربيه اقتصاد الايراني منها لدينا
كثير من الاختلاصات كل يوم يخرجوا يعني
بارق
ام دائما الحكومات الاستبداديه لا يتحملون
مسؤوليه اعمالهم وافعالهم ودائما يحق ان
في هذه القضيه لا يوجد لديهم عقوبات او
دول ممكن ان يسموها لذلك يقولون مؤامره
كونيه طبعا ايران دائما في واجهه مؤامره
ضدها نحن بنشكرك على هذه المداخله كانت
معنا منى السيلاوي الباحثه في الشان
الايراني من بروكسل شكرا لك
اهلا من جديد ما في سيره لمحبي كره القدم
في العالم امس الا مباراه مانشستر يونايتد
وليفربول واللي انتهت سبعه صفر لصالح
ليفربول المباراه من قبل ما تبداوا
الانظار متجهه يعني بتجمع نتيجه كبار
والتوقعات كانت منوعه لكن ما احد ابدا
اتوقع هذه النتيجه المذله بكل صراحه لمان
يونايتد فالفريق من سنه
31/1931 ما خسر اي مباراه بهذه النتيجه
واخر مره ليفربول دخلوا في مرمى 7 اهداف
كان في
1895 يعني من 128 سنه وقتها خلصت النتيجه
7-1 لكن امس 7-0 يعني حتى شرف انهم يدخلوا
هدف واحد المساكين ما قدروا عليه فدخل في
مرماهم هدف في الشوط الاول وسته في الشوط
الثاني اما انهم كانوا رايحين يلعبوا
ليفربول في ارضه بكل ثقه يعني الجماعه لهم
11 مباراه متتاليه ما خسروا الاسبوع اللي
فات جايبين كاس الرابطه واللي كان اول لقب
للنادي بال 2017 ويعني الامل كانت معلقه
يعني معنويات عاليه بس ليفربول حطمها كلها
الامل والمعنويات يعني بس اللي غير متوقع
في المباراه التاريخيه هذه انه يكون
رونالدو هو نجم التعليقات بعد المباراه
رونالدو اللي خلاص بيلعب في النصر ولا له
علاقه بمان يونايتد ولا له علاقه بليفربول
ليش تعالوا اذكركم رونالدو يعني كان اول
لاعب تحقق مع نجاحات مبهره بعدين ننتقل
الى ريال مدريد كمان انجازات مو طبيعيه
منا رحل يوفنتوس وبعد يوفنتوس رجع
لمانشستر يونايتد لكن الرجعه ما كانت زي
اول مره واخر فتره قبل ما يترك عانه كثير
في النادي خاصه من مدربو اريكتين اللي قعد
او قعد رونالدو على مقاعد الاحتياط اخر
فتره وهاجموا اكثر من مره في تصريحات
اخرها كان قبل المباراه هذه على طول وفيها
نسال عن شعور واتجاه قراره بعدم التجديد
لرونالدو وقال انه الفريق ما كان في
انضباط وقت وجود رونالدو وانه ندمان على
شيء وبينام ليل وهو مرتاح وما بيقلق لما
خلصت المباراه وانضرب مانشستر يونايتد
بالسبعه انهلت التعليقات والبوستات من كل
جهه وبكل اللغات وفي غالبيتها شماته مو
طبيعيه وبالطبع ابرز الشامتين كانوا محبين
رونالدو اللي اساسا لا بيشجعوا مانشستر
يونايتد ولا حتى ليفربول واكتار شافوا في
الموضوع انتقام من مانشستر يونايتد انه مو
بس يخزر بنتيجه مخجله ولكن كمان يكون عدد
الاهداف سبعه وهو رقم رونالدو الشهير
في ناس ما اكتفت بالصور والتعليقات واحتجت
فيديوهات عشان تشتري غليلهم تخيلوا فيها
رده فعل رونالدو على النتيجه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
خالص
والدنيا بص بص
وانت
اجمد كده لا لا بص ما تعيطش مش عايزك كده
اجمد
[موسيقى]
ايه
ايه سبعه نلعب فين نلعب مع الدحين ههه
سامعه يا جماعه
من ابرز المحبين والمدافعين عن رونالدو
الاعلامي البريطاني الشهير بيرس مورجان
وهذا عاد جنه حساباته لنصره رونالدو فعليا
كميه تغريدات تريد تويتر وتعليقات غير
طبيعيه ابرزها كان صوره لصحيفه او تصريح
مدرب مان يونايتد عن النوم ورونالدو وقال
له انه ان شاء الله تنام كويس اليوم يا
عبقري نشر كمان صوره
رونالدو من ظاهره مع الرقم 7 ونشر صوره
ثانيه هو شخصيا مع رونالدو من لقائهم اخير
سواء واللي فجر في رونالدو كثير قنابل
وتسبب حتى وقتها في خروجه من مان يونايتد
وعلق عليها وقال هذا الشيء المضحك اللي
اسمه كارما ونشر كمان من كم ساعه صوره
لمدرب مانشستر يونايتد وسائل الاستقلال
ولا لا وكيف ممكن يكمل بعد النتيجه
الكارثيه هذه على فكره عمل كمان رويت
لفيديو لجماهير ليفربول في المباراه وفيها
كانوا بيهتفوا باسم رونالدو للسخريه من
مدرب خصمهم في المباراه مانشستر يونايتد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وما تقدر تجي سيره مباراه امس وما نتكلم
عن الانجاز التاريخي اللي حققوا محمد صلاح
واللي بتسجيل هدفين صار الهداف التاريخي
لليفربول ب 190 29 هدف متغلبا على رقم
صاحب رقم القياسي سابقا روبي اللي كان فيه
128 هدف اللافت اكثر من انجاز محمد صلاح
تحطيمه للرقم القياسي هذا مع انه لعب 61
مباراه اقل من
الصحافه سالت صلاح بعد المباراه ايش راح
يعمل اليوم وكيف راح يحتفل قال لهم راجع
البيت احتفل مع العيله واشرب شاي ببابونج
وانا
نبقى في عالم كره القدم وخبر ثاني من
الجزء الاخر لكن من العالم فالمعروف في كل
مباريات كره القدم انه الفريقين اللي راح
يلعبوا ضد بعض ويدخلوا من ممر خاص بيخرجوا
في من غرف تبديل الملابس للملعب لكن اللي
صار في مباراه في دوري زامبيا كسر القواعد
وغير الدخول المالوف والمعروف لي اللاعبين
فلاعبي فريق لموانا دخلوا الملعب بطريقه
مختلفه تماما ومو متوقعه نطلب من فوق
السور
مثل ما شفتوا اللاعبين ما دخلوا من الممر
لا قفزوا من فوق سور الملعب غرابه الخبر
مو بس كيف دخلوا لكن كمان في الاسباب
فالسبب وراء نط فوق السور هو انهم خايفين
من السحر بحسب وسائل الاعلام ذنبيه لاعبي
فريق
لمس عرفوا انه منافسينهم في فريق جرين
بيستخدموا السحر عشان يفوزوا عاملين السحر
هذا في غرفه الملابس والممر للملعب فقرروا
ينطوا من فوق السور عشان يتفادوا السحر
طبعا وفي كلام منتشر يعني عن استخدام
السحر بين انديه افريقيا وفي كلام واخبار
دائما عن اللجوء لاعبين وانديه للسحر
والشعوذه لتحقيق اهداف معينه يعني بشكل
لكن اللافت عاد بعد المباراه كان انه
الفريق اللي نط عشان خايف من السحر
وتاثيره على اداءه ورغم النط من فوق السور
لكن برضو خسر المباراه وهنا عاد المنافس
ما فوت الفرصه فوته ايه استمروا طبعا
يسخروا منهم ونشروا على فيسبوك صور
اللاعبين كيف دخلوا الملعب وقالوا
لمتابعينهم في حال فاتكم الخبر اليوم
فزنا وترى منافسينا كده دخلوا الملعب
احنا وصلنا لختام حلقه اليوم دائما تابعوا
فيديوهات حلقه اليوم واخبارنا الاخرى على
صفحاتنا على مواقع التواصل ويعني دائما
نتفرجوا على مقاطعنا لانه فعلا مقاطعنا
حلوه ما يحتاجها واقول لكم انها حلوه
لانها حلوه مشاهدينا ان شاء الله في امان
الله
[موسيقى]